remettre ça en contexte dans
quelques minutes, parce que
d'ordures il y en a les uns
après les autres.
- Des zones de durs balances
pour Céline.
- - Mais d'abord, Docteur Garne,
bonsoir.
- Bonsoir.
- Qu'est-ce que c'est que la
syndrome de la personne raide et
expliquez-moi ça?
- C'est une condition auto-
immune dans laquelle les
anticorps vont s'attaquer à une
partie du système nerveux qui
permet normalement la relation
musculaire.
Vous comprendrez que si le
système permettant une
relaxation musculaire est
défectueux, la personne va
expérimenter des contractions
musculaires involontaires,
incontrôlables qui vont mettre
les muscles dans un état raide
ou rigide.
Là-dessus, ça peut imposer des
spasmes qui vont faire en sorte
que les s s s s tout d'un coup
se contractent.
Donc, vous aurez compris qu'une
personne qui souffre d'un tel
syndrome va avoir de la
difficulté avec la fluidité de
ses mouvements.
- Donc, évidemment, ne pourrait
pas monter sur scène.
Est-ce que ça se guérit?
Est-ce qu'il y a des
médicaments, passez-moi les
questions très naïves, pour
régler ça?
Ou est-ce qu'on a ça et on la
pour toujours?
- Ce qui est important à
spécifier, ce n'est pas une
condition neurodégénérative dans
laquelle la personne va devenir
complètement atteinte ayant
décédé.
C'est une condition po
laquelle nous avons des
traitements qui vont contrôler
les symptômes.
Le plus fréquent qu'on utilise,
c'est le diazépam, c'est un
nageant ererererermettre la
relaxation musculaire et
contrôler les symptômes.
Par contre on parle de contrôle
davantage que d'une cure de la
condition.
C'est difficile de s'en départir
complètement.
- Donc, vous dîtes qu'on ne
asasasasasas, on peut atténuer s
symptômes, atténuer les spasmest
pas.
Si c'est vraiment ça qu'elle a,
on ne guérit pas de ça.
Donc, la question que tous les
gens se posent : est-ce qu'elle
pourra retourner sur s
chanter?
- C'est difficile de me
prononcer parce qu'évidemment je
ne connais pas son dossier.
Par contre qu'on peut dire ce
qu'il y a de l'espoir d'avoir le
contrôle desavavavavavavavec la
médication.
En plus, Madame Dion, dans son
allocution a bien spécifié
qu'elle était entourée de
médecins et d'autres thérapeutes
pour l'aider à reprendre de
l'activité physique et se
mobiliser pour atténuer de façon
globale ces symptômes.u'u'u'u'ue
la maladie soit une condition
entièrement guérissable, on peut
quand même voir chez des
patients des rémissions des
symptômes grâce à nos
traitements.
- Donc, quand on dit que c'est
très rare, est-ce que vous en
avez vu, est-ce que vous n'en
voyez?
- C'est extrêmement rare.
Donc... je ne suis pas en
pratique depuis de si nombreuses
années, mais j'ai quand même vu
un cas. C'est rare au point
d'avoir environ une personne sur
1 million par années qui vont
être diagnostiquées avec ce
syndrome.
C'est plusieurs centaines de
fois plus rares que la majorité
des maladies neurologiques que
l'on voit au l l l l l l l l la
sclérose en plaques ou la
maladie de Parkinson.
Plusieurs neurologues
n'enverront pas de leur
caononononononononon a un diagna
personne raide, est-ce qu'on est
sûr que c'est ça?
Est-ce qu'il y a un doute
autrement dit?
- Je ne peux pas me prononcer
sur le cas de Madame Dionififif.
En général, c'est certain que
c'est un diagnostic qui est
assez compliqué à établir du
fait qu'on se base sur dessympte
plusieurs tests qu'on appelle
paracliniques. Dans l'examen
l'étude des mouvements
musculaires, qui permette de
supporter la confiance dans
notre diagnostic.
Sur le Madame gardon, merci
nous avoir éclairé sur cette
maladie rare.
Ma Godine l l l l l l l l l l a
carrière de Céline, c'est un
autre coup dur.
Celui-là est peut-être plus dur
que les autres, mais c'est un
autre coup dur.
- Je pense qu'elle a constaté
ypypypypypypypypypypype de
maladie qu'elle avait, ça allait
possiblement ralentir ses
activités professionnelles.
J'ai l'impression qu'aujourd'hui
on avait décidée d'aller
publique. Les gens pensaient
qu'elle avait développé un
caprice, en disant : la COVID
c'était le fun j'ai pu reprendre
un peu ma vie.
Céline, Hassan, c'est son
deuxième chez-soi, ell
bien.
C'est dans son ADN.
Et quand elle dit dans son vidéo
qu'elle s'ennuie et qu'elle a de
retrouver la scène et de jouer
pour ces ventes, je la crois ce
n'est vraiment pas du théâtre.
- Mettait en p
tournée qu'elle reporte encore
une fois.
C'est une grosse tournée?
- Dans les jours qui ont suivi,
il y avait des concerts qui ont
été reportés à cause qu'elle
avait des problèmes avec sa
voix.
e e e e e e e e e e e e e avaita
voix de plus en plus fragile.
Ça va jusqu'à la mi-mars enn n t
arrivé, tout est arrêté dans
l'industrie du spectacle.
C'est là l'enfant qu'elle a
monté son sens.
- Il y a des dates prévues de
ces tournées "courages".
- Les détourner jusqu'en 2024,
je n'ai jamais ça pour une
tournée.
Pour un album, pour un projet
spécifique, c'est une des
premières fois qu'on voit ça.
Est-ce qu'on va se rendre
jusqu'en 2024, c'est la grosse
question.
Ça c'est difficile de faire des
pronostics.
On vienne entendre Docteur
Garneau, mais c'est légitime de
se poser la question : est-ce
qu'elle pourra encore retourner
sur scè
- Dans les différentes
intrusions accordées, ça va
dépendre de L.
Est ce qu'elle veut retourner
sur cinq et avoir l'allure de
Phil Collin. Est-ce que Céline
est prête à faire ça?
Je ne crois pas.
J'ai l'impression qu'on va
analyser toutes les situations
et c'est quand même dans ses
mains.
Si les médecins lui disent :
oui, vous pouvez chanter.
Est-ce que lorsqu'elle sera en
concert et que la voix manque ou
que les différentes réactions,
est-ce que ça va lui tenter de
prendre le risque?
Je crois que c'est pour ça que
tout a été déplacé à l'année
prochaine en 2023, en septembre.
Sur le j'ai l'impression que
depuis la mort de René Angélil,
c'est coup dur sur coup dur
comme le disait.
On a l'impression que c'est plus
difficile.
Est-ce que c'est une impression?
Est-ce que c'est vrai ou c'est
injuste?
- Ces différents. Quand le
premier album avait été lancé
avec René, ça comme une
continuité.
Mais quand elle est arrivée avec
l'album "Courage", ainsi
retrouvé en première position à
la première semaine de parution.
Quand tu achetais le biais de
spectacles, tu avais droit à
l'album.
Ça été modifié au niveau de
cette acceptation.
Ce qui est arrivé c'est que la
semaine suivante et s'est
retrouvé dans les position 150,
c'était la chute vertigineuse.
Ce sont de drôles situations
comme ça qui sont arrivés.
- Ça n'a pas aidé le moral.
- Exactement, je ne pense pas
que ça avait quitté.
Je ne pense pas que c'est le
meilleur album qu'elle a fait,
elle aurait dû faire un album
plus solide.
- Est la question que vous allez
vous poser, c'est est-ce que ça
aurait été son dernier ou pas?
Elle sera en mesure d'aller
chanter en studio.
- Des albums, mais rarement des
spectacles.
- S'il y a des complications, on
va arrêter reparte par après.
Quand on est André, c'est
différ